we have seen that if you have a circle
with radius r then its area is pi r
squared but why so let's see another
method to prove this let us take a
circle with radius r
inside it let's draw many concentric
circles
taking the outermost circle we will make
a straight line like this
and in a similar way if we take the
inner circles and place straight lines
like this then the figure will look
something like this
we know that the outer circle
circumference is 2 pi r so this length
will be 2 pi r
what will this length be equal to
if you look carefully you'll notice that
will be equal to the radius
and the area of a triangle is one half
multiplied by its base multiplied by its
height substituting the values and
solving it further we get pi r squared
so now we know why the area of a circle
is pi r squared for more such
interesting math concepts please
subscribe to our youtube channel